Europe always struck me as a land full of languages.
Big Ones like German and Italian ones you may have never heard of like freely in
or visio.
Yarish gazing over from the u s it looks like a linguistic playground.
Ask the experts though and you might get a different view.
A grammatically flat vanilla uniform Europe where the language is shared.
Common.
You're reversals.
It's the 1930s Benjamin Lee wharf is struggling to understand how the Hopi talk
about time.
Wait,
but hope he's not a European language.
I know we'll get there.
Warf is about to make a controversial breakthrough.
The Hopi don't have concepts for past,
present,
and future.
He says because they speak Hopi.
We on the other hand,
do see time this way because we speak standard,
average European.
Even if you've never set foot in linguistics class,
you've likely heard part of this claim before.
The concepts in your mind are relative to the language you speak,
but I don't see as many of you debating that second part,
the standard average European.
I'm here to change that.
So warf.
Let's say we met a standard average European,
what would they sound like?
Well,
not like any single language.
They'd have common patterns that are definitively European.
Now,
early attempts to listen for such patterns.
Drew bold conclusions from just a handful of languages.
German,
French and English do it.
So it must be European.
Now,
depending on which expert you trusted,
it started to seem like any language in Europe.
Both was and was not standard.
Average European.
Everyone felt like there was some core heartland of shared European ness,
but they couldn't agree on specifics.
By the 90s dissatisfied linguists were demanding a more rigorous approach.
If you can't find one,
make one.
So the European Science Foundation funded euro cheap,
a huge project to collect data about the typology of over 130 European
languages.
Everything from word order to tenses and flow of time to the all important
adverbial subordinates.
These are little words like,
because if,
although the man responsible for collecting these little words used them to make
general statements called Euro versales.
See the field of topology was already hunting for universals things.
True of every human language.
So here we have euro reversals about all European languages.
These make for some light bedtime reading and I promise check out your reversal
number one when you have the time,
the hunt for your reversals didn't stop at grammar though like in this more
recent search for widespread idioms where we discovered that shedding crocodile
tears isn't unique to English.
At least 45 languages in Europe were found a fake.
They're sobbing with the same of phrase,
but all of these researchers admit we're still lacking important data.
What's wrong with our picture?
What are we still missing?
Well,
it's one thing to read your reversal number one quite another.
When the author goes on to say this could just be a universal,
it's one thing to find out that Europe cries crocodile tears quite another.
When you learn the same idiom appears in Swahili and Mongolian.
If we want to know what makes Europe unique,
we need to compare non European languages.
We got that comparison in 2001 finally a serious look at features pervasive in
Europe but uncommon around the world.
What was it?
All our cane,
thorny grammatical nitpicks.
Actually most of it is straight forward stuff here.
Let's play a game called you might be a European,
you might be a European.
If you have a word for both d and a,
If you use have as a helping verb saying things like have done and have seen you
might be a European.
If you use a little word like then in comparisons you might be a,
yeah,
sorry that got old,
but also if your word for self is different from your reflexive Pronoun.
If you're an English speaker,
these might sound normal enough to make you shrug until you got to that last
one,
which works for German and Spanish,
but not English.
It's okay.
I know nobody wants to hear their languages less European than German,
but what if it is,
let's find out.
Let's count these features and score the languages against each other.
Tallying and mapping the nine features that have complete data.
We get a geography of your reversals.
It's a bold and cohesive unit.
Germanic languages,
Romance,
Slavic,
Baltic,
Greek,
Hungarian,
Albanian,
all of them with five or more features.
Then it's a steep drop off down to languages that have hardly any Maltese in the
south.
Baskin Celtic in the West,
Turkish in Georgia and in the east finishing Estonian in the north.
We have our boundaries,
but is there a core,
well,
there is one area with a high concentration of nine features right here,
centered around France and Germany dubbed the Charlemagne area,
and I'll notice that English is a couple notches outside of that Charlemagne
core,
despite being a close relative of one of the languages and a heavy borrower from
another,
we've been calling this standard average European,
but it may not be so standard or average on the world scene.
Instead of default,
it's actually been called downright exotic.
Wow.
Did it a continent and UB sharing exotic features and then convincing us that
these features were just plain normal.
The answer,
but would take up another video and it's really just a bunch of maybes.
Maybe we can blame the migrations and upheavals of the Middle Ages,
perhaps the widespread use of Latin.
Maybe these languages have constantly been adjusting to one another,
but one thing's for sure,
the search for a genetic root,
a shared ancestry behind these features won't cut it.
Europe's languages,
it seems,
aren't exotically standard and average because of what they've inherited,
but because of what they've shared as they shape the continent into a unique
language area.
Well,
except maybe for you,
Celtic and Basque.
Stick around and subscribe for language.